foreign
[Music]
test run here but can we talk about how
any reasonable human being thought this
security was even close to acceptable
enough to begin with you have multiple
openings in your roof that apparently
have no alarms on them and can be opened
from the outside you do know you can
have skylights that aren't also entry
points right second you decide to set up
a laser grid but then make them a single
plane of six foot by six foot squares
why even have them in the first place
what if Catherine Zeta Jones stops in
that's barely going to be any fun to
watch third those lasers are so high off
the ground Jabba the Hut could crawl
under them and if you can't stop a Hut
you're basically begging for your stuff
to be stolen do you know how hard it is
to lay on your stomach prop up on your
elbows then rotate your left wrist to
fully face the person beside you to flip
them off in full frontal fashion well I
do why the hell is your phone on movie
theaters if we show San Marino the flaws
in their palace security they've agreed
to hire us as security consultant
considering this is a mission briefing
they almost certainly had before the
mission started I can only assume that
Mallory accidentally called Archer
instead of the audience as intended damn
it what the hell are they even doing on
these wires they shot a wire to attach
to both sides so they could hover travel
instead of crawl I swear this show
thinks it just exists to crack jokes and
mock spy entertainment instead of
providing reasonable and detailed
spycraft practices based in reality and
authenticity how is Mallory holding this
phone to her ear it's clearly nowhere
near her shoulder I suppose she has spy
earrings that magnetize to the phone
somehow making her busy phone life
easier what am I saying where's her
headset because you learned nothing from
it I learned that flammable and
inflammable mean the same thing the
English language oh my God we've been
spotted and they're shooting at us oh oh
God
he's freaking out right now not
understanding your mother even one
percent discount Jagermeister and yes we
would have sent actual Jagermeister for
being product placement welcome to TVC
s to step on the ants and
dance just knock off the giggling sure
but you're gonna have to give me a
reason to start first all of San Marino
could fit in the South Bronx judging a
country by its size does the South Bronx
have the oldest known Constitution still
in use today Google says I don't think
so Mallory
are you cheating on me no just trying to
get my muffin back so yes then you got a
slugger in the diaphragm with a forearm
shiver weird safe sex euphemisms see
time lost his muffin lost along with my
appetite for food that is Cheryl has
deviant horniness an attempt to get us
to King shamer cliche as for hiring Odin
Odin having a video conferencing camera
that comes with the built-in automatic
zoom out for dramatic reveal setting or
a convenient zoom out for dramatic
reveal human operator with a working
copy of the script
presumably important Captain region of
San Marino and none of his off-camera
security appear to have an issue with
this even from a basic hygiene
standpoint because I've swallowed just
about as much as I can take from you hey
freezing phrasing sure it's first time
was a quickie in episode 4 but this is
where the king of entender retorts
really thrusts itself into pop culture
in a deep way a sent off for this
Mammoth running gag being the runniest
and gaggiest we've ever experienced wait
you want us to break back into the
palace which now has the insane amount
of security we recommended Lana would be
excellent at TV since and yet she still
chooses to work for Isis letting your
crackers touch the Cesspool that's the
community workplace eating table you
might as well just Mainline
streptococcus at this point guess who
has breast cancer
[Music]
just one of like two dozen equally
appalling videos on your website but who
was filming it the camera started on
this woman turned to Pam and Cheryl and
then turned back to the lady who's the
accomplice draw me someone else to be
angry at damn it she keeps seducing me
blaming your choices on your libido my
point is urges do not equal action Cyril
own your [__] choices literally
what's my father ever done that's so
great
[Music]
and you can take her home to meet your
dick dad and then I shove his Hawk face
right into her big brown boobs and
scream look at these babies old man
Cyril is not my son in this scene the
computer processing power dedicated to
this completely unnecessary rotating
Globe what are you doing back there I
don't know what are you just hitting
random Keys expecting Archer or any
person glued to a glass of scotch to
have any clue what these keys do is Lana
new here ah damn it we where is The
Hobbit guy thing I've been constantly
asking while waiting for Peter Jackson
to direct another narrative feature film
somehow makes it into this episode
testing your high-tech sleep masks on
the wrong part of your crash test dummy
storing your acid above your beer unless
of course you enjoy the potential for
corrosive drippage into your fermented
beverages I remember what Miss Archer
did to the cleaning ladies okay
wait are we saying Miss Archer actually
killed three employees and everyone
knows about it and everyone is still
fine working here and everyone knows
about it and everyone is still fine
working here and they know about it and
their fine work Show refuses to give us
an episode featuring each of these
employees if this was The Simpsons every
one of these people would be a key part
of their world with their own character
quirks and lives Justice for background
extras this was all I could find I'm
thinking goggles yes shovels
um actually Archer only this one is a
shovel this is a Spade TV sins doing the
good Lord's work since 2018. you want
unfair when do we want it change it
wasn't until the strike chant writers of
America got to the picket line that they
realized the terrible bind they had put
themselves in nobody knows why we're
striking well we can't say hey right
upstairs is a top secret intelligence
agency yes you can Cyril clearly
demonstrating that he has no idea how
leveraging works not wanting to animate
a side view of your character so
desperately that you just have four of
them break the fourth wall and stare
directly into the audience's soul so
let's go out the back I am absolutely
shocked that the back door was an option
number one especially for Archer
number one with salary and performance
incentives a lot of bonuses bonuses this
is apparently brand new information to
the person who is head of accounting for
Isis massive headwind serial here hasn't
applied any pressure or gauze or
anything against this gaping gash and
his face should be drowning in blood the
very least Cheryl should have knitted
him a forehead tampon by now how many
are there about a jillion using
hyperbolic numbers in tactical
situations also at what point is the
cost of protecting something outweigh
the value of the thing itself asking for
my virginity friends my my friends
Virginia
do we take the drones for granted
Michael Bay's ambulance no no no that is
utterly unacceptable it's just a cost of
living adjustment it's strong armed
robbery wow these are reasonable
concessions and Mallory isn't budging
one bid can you imagine if this happened
in the real world people asking for a
fair wage in so-called industry leaders
on huge salaries with massive bonuses
shooting them down what a shitty world
that would be go ahead crank up the heat
I'm as naked as the day I was born
acting like every last one of you
wouldn't give everything just to be the
Olive in her martini glass I've said too
much and that's the game Lana survival
just watch Deliverance again huh
learning all the wrong lessons from
Deliverance I mean this rattles not the
man in that Ronnie Cox Erasure you know
we did all his own stuff I know
his own stuck it's really hard to
believe I should root for Lana over
Archer when she does stupid [__] like
yell at the top of her lungs while on a
stealth Mission standing straight up and
above your cover while jillions of
machine guns fire at you he loves tempoy
just needs you to upload the GPS
coordinates into his HUD do you mean HUD
why are you saying the letters you
acronym squandering word butcher at that
point you might as well just say heads
up display it literally only costs you a
single extra syllable your use of
abbreviations is completely f-u-b-a-r
head to the Consumer Price Index
invading the privacy of the cpi's sex
life and yes I know that's stretching it
is what the CPI said after the number
finished this gin soaked dress
specifically
[Music]
about 15 freaking beers all that shootsy
and holy [__] did I honk down a bunch of
absence
cause I hallucinated you had an
engagement room
you didn't see anything
are you cheating on me we were on a
break you've ruined us I've ruined us
you got a lot of nerve honey the
millions you pissed away on clothing and
jewelry and Spa tree yes to keep you
interested the only thing you ever
appreciated
can I help you you got a fantastic body
then you can take her home to meet your
dick dad and then I shove his Hawk face
right into her big brown boobs and
scream now can I please have my
motorboat listen to your hearts Because
deep down you know they're exploiting us
the line must be drawn here there's fun
father we don't talk to management or
ham-fisted [__] what dad there's like
[__] here and stuff sweetheart how
many times have I told you don't say and
stuff just say dad they're a horse here
Jesus the goggles the goggles do nothing